it's time for drew's news your daily
swing in that good news hammock
and with me at the desk my trusty
co-pilot i'm the luckiest girl in the
world rossi ross mouth oh that makes me
the luckiest boy
yo
um first up joshua jackson you know
pacey from dawson's creek oh i know yeah
and um he was on the affair
he loves the affair
well he's all grown up now as we know
and he has a steamy new role on the new
tv reboot of get ready for this one
fatal attraction oh this is a good one
where has this been all these years oh
my god i'm so into the concept great
idea
i'm not going to be ignored damn dan
oh my god it's the best movie ever
so there's lots of sexy scenes in it and
one fan who can't wait to watch
is his wife
that's right insider reports that jody
turner smith says she loves watching
joshua's love scenes because he is a sex
symbol and in real life that's right
that's how she sees him and she wants
him to lean into it miss turner smith
said
and i quote
i can't wait to see my husband
blankety-blanking on screen again did
you watch the affair
that's her quote uh-huh ross thought
well that's evolved uh
you're all clapping like great for her
okay good but if that was your husband
or your wife would you want to watch
them in a love scene with somebody else
no
i'm not a jealous type of person but if
my wellington is watching try it
no
i think this is fun because she's made
it an empowering sexy thing she could
feel like a victim that she felt bad
that her husband does this but i think
her spin is quite sexy and empowering
i'm in okay i'm into all right uh next
up so i'm ross matthews your reality tv
reporter and i've got some fresh scoop
uh anyone here watch love is blind
everybody's talking about this show
well i actually watched the first part
of the reunion on the train in today of
love is blind i'm obsessed and if you
are too um but you're upset it's ending
turn that frown upside down because the
ultimatum is a new show uh people
reports netflix's newest reality show
premieres april 6th nick and vanessa
lachey who host love is blind they're
back at the helm of this one and here's
the premise they start with six couples
who are on the verge of marriage but one
person in each couple is not so sure and
then they have eight weeks to figure it
out but there's a little twist listen
what happens they will each pick a new
partner from the group and try living
with that person as a couple
to see what life would be like with
somebody else
i feel the exact opposite way
as i do about jody turner smith this is
a recipe for disaster yeah
it makes me
so uncomfortable
it is so uncomfortable to think about
this and i am so angry that i will watch
every second of this
single second i'm gonna hate watch it i
am of course i mean it just seems like a
disaster waiting to happen yes sabotage
and i'm sure gonna get high ratings it
is yes but it also begs the question
about ultimatums in general you know
what i mean i i didn't think about it
from that perspective ross well think
about that if you're in a relationship
and one of you was like let's get
married let's get married and the other
person is dragging their feet
i have a spoiler alert it's probably not
going to end well right because if
somebody doesn't want to marry you what
else do you need to know
so that being said i'm sure this show is
going to be a hit i will report back to
you every detail
[Music]